ross take it away this is your story
well i'm a big football fan are you a
fan of oh my god this is all i do i'm
going to be in morning after sunday when
i don't have football until next august
it's going to be hard who's your team
uh you know what i'll be happy either
way because i went to university of
georgia matt stafford quarterback for
the rams is a georgia guy so he's a
bulldog so i got to be happy for him but
it's been so long for cincinnati
if they win that would be amazing so i'm
good either way okay well that's great
so you're going to be happy on sunday no
matter what as long as i get to eat food
i'm good exactly and you know last year
how about this an estimated 16.1 million
americans plan to skip work the day
after the super bowl maybe they're um
eating maybe they're drinking they're
just partying yeah um and so usa today
reports a high school student named
frank ruggieri says he has a solution
for all that lost productivity how about
this move the super bowl to saturday
hello yes brilliant
and he started a petition online it
already has a hundred and twenty
thousand signatures i actually went on
and signed it myself for you yeah hello
right we're all home we want to watch on
saturday and then recover let the bloat
come down from the hot wings on sunday
um uh the nfl they said they may even
get some more ratings you know and kids
could watch and not have to worry about
school the next day so i'm wondering
will you guys sign this petition
i don't sign petitions but i totally
endorse this i think it's a brilliant
idea because
um
it just you're it just it makes so much
sense why wouldn't you exactly and and
the super bowl i'm sure there there are
people who want to travel to go to the
game but have work on monday
um it's true i'm sure some people are
not feeling great the next day because
they had the best time ever as they
should and it's late the game goes
really late late and if your team wins
you're celebrating and if your team
loses you're
and i just think you know maybe because
it's super both sunday it's
all the s's well super bowl saturday is
still a very essy you know the reason
they do it they protected college
football and high school football
they they set it up that the nfl would
play on sundays so that the college
games and the high school games wouldn't
have competition but there is no other
football game on super bowl sunday they
can make one exception yes for super
bowl sunday and move it to saturday i'm
you you got my vote kid that's what you
got
little frank has fixed it um
all right and it's your story all right
and this one as i think probably
everybody knows last week there was a
big party in the uk when queen elizabeth
became the first british monarch to
celebrate her platinum jubilee that's 70
years as queen which is amazing
phenomenal it is great but here's the
deal it begins a year-long jubilee a
year-long celebration but there's just
one little hitch
take a look at the souvenirs that were
printed
now if you look at this it's the queen's
jubilee but there was a little problem
can we zoom in on this and show them
that instead of the word jubilee it says
jubbly oh now i play word with friends
and that is not a word
you do not get any points for jubbly
so good news is for collectors this
stuff is now worth a fortune but
somebody you know back in the old day
off with their heads right into the
tower uh-huh i can't hear the queen say
it like jubbly
but the juggly what is jubbly it isn't
isn't it a saying over there i don't
know it's a bit juggly yes i don't think
so i think that describes you know when
i haven't been working out too yeah
that's me after super bowl sunday i'm a
little juggly up here
all right next up a new poll just asked
2 000 americans an impossible question
what is the best tv show ever ross
debra can you pick what won i have no
idea what one i mean if i were voting
you know my childhood ross once jim in
the holograms and say by the bell to win
but i would um i don't i mean sex in the
city would be my vote now
oh that's a good one right what would be
your vote i don't know i'd be thinking
like a cartoon or something but i'm sure
that's not the right answer so i'm gonna
what would yours be if you got to say
what like your your favorite i loved
petticoat junction when i was a kid
don't ask me why um and i love the other
one with um ava gabor um green acres oh
yeah i just thought you know how did she
have those beautiful outfits living in a
shack i didn't
how would understand
be
i i don't know why i immediately went to
like cheers oh that was a good one
i'm binging that right now on hulu by
the
way
from beginning it there's
shelley long ted danson and the episode
where she leaves is just one of my
favorite most haunted so maybe that's
the answer well
uh the daily news reports that the
number one rated show was fred
oh okay
and then this is shocking because of
course seinfeld that could have easily
taken the top spot but that came in a
close second followed by game of thrones
yes then three's company and then
frasier and the simpsons made the top
ten coming in at number nine and
sopranos at 13.
[Music]
i don't know about sopranos at 13. yeah
should be a little higher i also like
the west wing too that's such a great
show right mad men mad men could be up
there there's so many good shows that's
the point i loved 24. oh i was
overwhelmed
we had a rule in the studio if you
hadn't seen it within the second day too
bad we're talking about it yeah it's on
you yeah you got to watch it i love it
well i love these debates and i love
television and guess what we get to come
back and do more of it we'll be right
back
[Music]
you